first to me is like like go-karts when
you're an adult like I love the idea of
go-karts and then I go get on a go-kart
and I go around the track a few times
and I'm like I'm a grown-ass man I could
drive a car like I [ __ ] doing this for
it and so fireworks I get it like right
when I was a kid it was like oh my god
we get to light the lighter and it'll
[ __ ] light and then it'll explode and
[ __ ] but I'm a grown-ass man I got weed
what the [ __ ] do I need
I see fireworks every day a big like a
professional display Stosh isn't
professional and online no I'm not I'm
really really not into the like oh god
it's exploding [ __ ] I got dogs too and
the older one just kept freaking out and
lived near the Hollywood Bowl so that
two shows and like at the end of the
first show I didn't know there are two
shows the end of the first shows a
[ __ ] gigantic [ __ ] it's like the
Valentine's Day Massacre somebody's
getting killed that's just
buh-buh-buh-buh so then the dog went
apeshit mad - like literally hold her
down and hold her and be like it's okay
and she's looking at you like why aren't
you [ __ ] worried their comment
they're coming Isis is here you know and
so you try to explain it's like now it's
[ __ ] because we love this country
that's why we try to blow small pieces
of it up I guess so
just once she calmed down like I was
like right on that's it [ __ ] she'll
be okay and then Jennifer's like there's
a second show yeah so they oh [ __ ] you
got any drugs and so there's a drug for
one of the other dogs the rescue dog
that we got mm-hmm keeps her kind of
chill so she's like I'm gonna give Louie
that was the one freaking out what a
Marty that's the other dogs I'm gonna
give her a Louie Marty spilling [ __ ] so
she gives dolly downers tote very much a
doggie dammit so she gives it to her and
dude like [ __ ] my wife thank God I
never showed an interest in like oxys or
anything like that because she gives the
pill of the dog and literally three
minutes later she's like we should
probably do another one first man giving
CPR to your dog a half an hour later
because it's overdosed or maybe the dog
was just like I don't know maybe the
humans feel like the enemy is on our
doorstep here's the suicide
she just seems so [ __ ] baffled and
confused but the other one the first one
kicked in dude she went down hard yeah
drugs are great yeah she was pretty it's
pretty it made me like [ __ ] keep an
eye on my wife cuz I'm like you have
this kind of potency at your fingertips
at all times she's gonna she's gonna
dose you and you're gonna be out dial M
for murder my fat husband yeah people
are concerned about the dogs and the
fireworks and I get I'm a dog owner
myself but we've been having fireworks
for 200 years and it seems like just
lately there's been a big thing about
the dogs and the fireworks you have a
dog yes you know I do have a dachshund
just like you oh you do yeah Reggie the
wonder dog yes yeah well we don't talk
about your [ __ ] dachshund in my house
we got one whenever we talk about a
wonder dog it's Shecky [ __ ] Reggie oh
those gods enter one dog leaves man oh
my god a wiener fighter your fight let's
do it I'm ready to do it all right
here's a real one cuz I bought I bought
one I thought was real but it was a
miniature dachshund that's what I have I
have an introduction oh my god so we got
to the fight battle of the mini wieners
yeah just like real life throw them in a
pit see what happens if is your dog like
you like you know we all know your well
we don't know much about your dick but
we know your balls are huge yes yeah
does your dog eat dog boy yes you still
have his balls no you took them of
course
why cuz you could be the only one with
big balls and I'm the only man in this
house [ __ ] Reggie the wonder
eunuch no you get your dogs spayed and
neutered why just gets [ __ ] the guy
from cuz Bob that's better for them it's
healthier for them they say that if
you're not planning on breeding them
it's healthy you're with them well here
I'm just gonna throw this out there
maybe this isn't every dog but I had a
yellow lab molder and early on we had to
yell to yellow as mulder and scully was
the 90s and so
like from day one they were like you got
to cut his balls off cuz they'll get
ball cancer one day and they died from
ball cancer and I couldn't do it I was
like you know what I'm not getting a
stood fixed like you know and he was
chill he never like he had a sister dog
skully and she wasn't his sister but
like you know he grew up with never
tried to [ __ ] her anything like that
maybe he was gay maybe you had a gay dog
we thought that and I hoped so because I
was like [ __ ] that's trendy but uh but
it wasn't that at all and because when
we got the little dog the miniature
dachshund he [ __ ] that and wore her
like a [ __ ] canine condom on his
[ __ ] deck yeah thanks for the visual
she was little but uh but in any event I
never I never cut his balls let him he
had his balls his whole life that dog
lived to be 17 right died in my arms
hmm must have been something you said
[Applause]
give him a break in any event no I'm the
other guy that's like don't cut the
balls off that's horseshit that's like
your mom going like eat chicken soup
that'll kill a cold that's just like
some horse shits been handed down from
medical professional to medical
professional and this newsrooms like
duct professional did dog dog lover -
dog lover man like he tried to I tried
to treat my dogs the way I treat like
myself and my friends and human beings
and [ __ ] and I would never be like Ralph
take him out then no more for you
concentrate on the show
I don't know your wife took your ball
some time ago so I'm surprised maybe
that's why I'm so [ __ ] open harder
about others keeping their
[Music]